You've had a lot of success,
and it's growing,
and I would imagine
you're starting to get noticed by people
from your stand-up.
Yeah.
You're starting
to get recognized.
Have you had that yet?
Where you've had people recognize you?
Yeah
And it's exciting,
like you've had VIPs recognize you?
Yes, one of my friends told me
that Scarlett Johansson was a big fan.
[Conan] Oh that's big.
Yeah, he told me,
and I was like,
"Why didn't she just tell me?"
(audience laughs)
"I'm easy to reach."
So I didn't know what to
do with that information,
'cause I can't hit her up, like,
"Hey Scarlett, I heard."
(audience laughs)
[Conan] Yeah.
"Where do we go from here?
What's the next step?"
[Conan] Right.
Then I'm at a club in New
York two months after that,
I see Scarlett Johansson in the club,
with a friend that knows her.
I say, "Hey, man,
introduce me to Scarlett.
I heard she's a fan.
But don't introduce me saying,
"Here's Hannibal, I heard you're a fan."
Introduce me regular-style,
and then we'll see how she plays."
Yeah, see if this is real, yeah.
Yeah, so we go up to her.
She says, "Hey, Scarlett,
this is Hannibal.
Hannibal, Scarlett."
She says, "Oh, Hannibal, I'm
a huge fan of your stand-up."
I say, "Thank you, Scarlett.
I'm a huge fan of pictures of you."
No, I didn't.
(audience and Conan laughs)
I didn't say that, you can't say
that type of stuff to people!
You think it, but you
don't say it right away.
You don't say it, no.
No, you don't say that type of stuff.
So now, what happened to that?
Did you become friends?
Did anything-
No, well, you know,
she's real nice.
She's very nice.
And two months later I'm in the same club
in New York, I turn around.
I'm in line for the bathroom,
I turn around, Scarlett
Johansson directly behind me.
[Conan] She's behind you
in line for the bathroom?
She's behind me in line for the bathroom.
So we speak briefly,
'cause we're very cool now
and I think most dudes,
you're next in line,
Scarlett right behind
you, you let her go ahead,
but you know what?
I'm not that dude.
(audience laughs)
(Conan laughs)
I'm not that dude, sorry.
I loved you in "Avengers"
" I loved you in "Avengers," Scarlett,
but I still gotta pee.
Everybody in this world
gotta pee, you know?
So you held your ground?
I held my ground.
You did not?
I would have let her go first.
'Cause I was thinking, maybe
in her mind she might go
"Oh wow, Hannibal didn't let me
go to the bathroom ahead of him.
But most punk-ass dudes would have.
I should marry this dude, right?"
You never know how women's minds work.
[Conan] You never know!
Rosario looked very skeptical about that.
[Hannibal] You know what, I was drunk.
So I think I messed up my
shot with her that night.
[Conan] You think you messed up your shot?
I was pretty faded and
whenever she would walk past me
in the club I would go "Scarlett".
(audience laughs)
"Scarlett"
Conan, I don't think it's
gonna work out with us.
But you know, you live and you learn.
[Conan] You live and you learn.
You adjust your game.
You should have learned
that in seventh grade.
(audience laughs)
"Scarlett"
That didn't work, but you know I was just,
you know, alcohol.
(audience laughs)
You can end any story that went badly
with alcohol.
Yeah.
Now is this true, that you got a show.
I heard exciting news
that you got a show picked
up on Comedy Central.
Is that right?
(crowd cheers and applauds)
Is that true?
This is exciting news.
I have a pilot with Comedy Central,
but they hadn't picked it up,
but I just said that they did.
You didn't just say that they did,
you tweeted.
[Hannibal] That's why you say stuff.
[Conan] You tweeted "I'm happy to announce
that Comedy Central
just picked up my series
"Unemployable" for 10 episodes."
[Hannibal] Yeah.
[Conan] Did you make
that up?
I didn't make it up, I just kind of
put my dreams out into the world.
(audience laughs)
(Conan laughs)
Now did you just send
out that one tweet or?
Well I just...You're supposed
to follow up on your dreams.
I just wanted to put
good energy out there.
So you put up another one.
Yeah.
[Conan] This is fantastic.
[Hannibal] 'Cause you gotta.
It's good energy!
It's positive energy!
It's positive energy.
I like that it's great.
It's not lying, it's not deceiving.
It's not deceiving, it's just saying
"I see the future and it involves you all
picking up my show or
let's make it weird."
Yeah.
(both laughs)
And if you get in any legal trouble,
you can just say "alcohol".
(all laughs)
Alcohol, sorry Comedy
Central, I was drunk.
I love you all Comedy Central.